my name is Ayesha costly wall I'm a
senior UI UX designer developer focusing
on design systems at twitch in San
Francisco previously I was a senior UX
engineer on the Lightning design system
team at Salesforce I consider myself a
designer who codes I care deeply about
design and that has what led me to focus
on many of the different aspects of how
design can be informed in tech and
that's why I write code today I want to
talk to you about how typescript can
power Design Systems I know most of the
people in this group are developers but
since design systems are growing so much
ideally you've heard of the term design
system before can you actually raise
your hand if you know what a design
system is so for those of you who don't
a design system is the single source of
truth
which groups all the elements that
allows team to design realize and
develop a product my old teammate and
friend Gina Ann of Design Systems Fame
has very eloquently described design
systems to be composed of tangible and
non tangible elements a design system
offers a consistent and well-designed
pattern library tools for both designers
and developers code ready components
guidelines and plenty of usable
resources at the same time a design
system also offers some abstract
elements like brand values shared ways
of working shared beliefs about the
product UI UX best practices and more
it's where development work intersects
with design work a design system
contains collections of rules which
include guidance as well as strictly
enforced UI UX and code behavior in the
product constraints and principles so
that your team at large is operating
under the same circumstances and
direction that are implemented in design
and in code some of the beauty of Design
Systems lies in the fact that the design
and code of the system carry all of
those rules constraints and guidelines
within them the design and code alone if
used and maintained can afford your
company clarity efficiency a standard
look and feel and unity a design system
actually goes beyond just design and
beyond just code a Design Systems team
like my own has to maintain an entire
product of their own so our customers
end up being designers and developers
that are in our own company my team
operates as a design focused engineering
team and the engineers in the rest of
our company use the components that we
provide because we do this we have to
maintain many aspects of our product
which includes a large variety of
different challenges
to build and maintain from support to
documentation to messaging and
everything in between a design system is
a very large body of work
a lot of companies both big and small
like Amazon Facebook Google and Shopify
have design systems and where I work
which is twitch which some of you may
have heard of does as well a lot of what
we maintain and what I tend to focus on
is component development think of a
component as small as a button or a
component as large as a modal we work to
build and maintain all of it the process
generally starts off as I da ting why a
specific component like a button is
necessary once we deem it important we
move on to design and then before it
goes into production we have to write
the code to build it for many Design
Systems teams the main concern is the
view layer and making sure there's a
clear and consumable API for our
company's engineers we write and
maintain our components in HTML CSS and
JavaScript and it turns out that in our
JavaScript we are able to maintain a lot
of opinions rules and documentation
around our designs and at which were
able to do that by using react j/s and
typescript
here's an example of that process from
our own design system we ideated that we
needed a very small UI element that
could convey status in line with other
elements and based on UX research and
best practices we decided that the best
UI to solve that problem would look like
a pill after I da ting we designed what
the pill component would look like this
is the pill in our figma UI kit that all
of our designers use then we wrote the
code for the pill in typescript which is
on the left side we created
documentation which is on the right side
and luckily because we're using
typescript it's really easy to generate
prop related documentation that's very
detailed and then finally in production
on the website the web app the mobile
app all of our different instances of
twitch the pill is used by designers and
developers when they want to convey
status in their UI so this is one
example of how it's used on our website
and this is another example of how it's
being used in production
so I mentioned that we use typescript in
our JavaScript stack because we believe
that it's a powerful tool when it comes
to design systems development but what
exactly is typescript
typescript is a typed superset of
JavaScript that compiles to plain
JavaScript a good summary of how it's
different from vanilla Jas is that it
provides optional static typing classes
and interfaces when using typescript you
don't have to write all of your code
entirely in typescript if you wanted to
you could have vanilla JavaScript and
typescript in the same file also you can
use typescript with react Jas a couple
of benefits that typescript provides
include style specific typed props
having style specific typed props offers
visual consistency ensures proper piss
and prevents variable mutations
if you use an IDE that is compatible
with typescript which most are at this
point the IDE is informed in real time
by the typescript compiler on its rich
type information
there's better autocomplete snippet
generation renaming and targeting across
the entire code base compilation errors
and more and these are some examples
from our code base directly if we
reference a component that hasn't been
imported the IDE will automatically add
it to our import list for us if you
start typing out an enum the IDE will
automatically reference all of the
possible values that you can use
typescript provides exportable
interfaces which makes communicating the
intents and limits of your component
seamless
an interface is basically the contract
that the component must conform to and
it states what needs to be or could be
done but doesn't specify how it will be
done an interface contains the name of
all of the properties along with all of
their types it also includes a signature
for functions along with the type of
arguments and the return type for
example the title function returns a
string in typescript you can also export
these interfaces allowing similar
components to share the same contracts
ensuring consistency so here we've made
an interface called core interactive
public props for anything that would
need to share link related interaction
design concerns
for our link component we've extended
the core link interface to use the same
core interactive public props so core
link will get things like the title prop
for free with added props that we want
to stay specific to core link like
underlined so how does typescript
specifically help Design Systems more
than anything
typescript helps create trust and a
stronger relationship between design and
development designers can trust that
their designs are being implemented
correctly
and developers can trust that they have
access to all of the information they
need about a component upon usage let me
explain that further as I was
researching typescript I came across a
really great phrase describing what
typescript is like interface oriented
development typescript encourages
developers to develop exposing
interfaces which keeps other developers
who use the components informed of what
the API consists of
typescript allows developers to focus on
exposed API rather than having to know
all the code by heart because of this
typescript can enable a softer
onboarding for code bases and especially
for design related and front-end
specific code which most developers
don't want to focus on the IDE has
really great autocomplete here's an
example of how we're able to achieve
developer trust by using typescript in
our design system like most design
systems we provide documentation for
component usage and guidelines something
great were allowed to do because of
typescript is static code analysis of
each components props so for our
component pagination control which you
saw here we have all of the possible
props you could use on this component
listed out in this interface in our
documentation if you go to the
properties tab of each component you'll
find those same props listed out for our
developers to easily reference
it's the same exact list of props with
additional information about what the
props type is and descriptions that we
generate from comments in the code
itself so you can see that the interface
is there we using static code analysis
took all of those props and turned them
into documentation we've taken it a step
further by also offering developers a
functional prate playground to test
components in with the same prop list as
well on each of our documentation pages
we offer a link to open a playground for
each component this is an example of
what a playground looks like the
playground offers developers a way to
configure all of the props use them and
work with them to create the version of
the component that they need the code
changes in real time as well so that
they could copy and paste the code if
they wanted to by having all of our
props per component listed out in
interfaces we're able to easily make use
of static code analysis and provide
better tooling for our developers and
for our designers
typescript also enables designer trust
take a component design as simple as
this a progress bar which we use on our
twitch website all over the place with
the combination of interfaces and enums
the components can include all possible
variations of design so the developer
can easily get the design right without
having to rely on copying and pasting
code knowing specific class names etc
the IDE will also include all of these
values through autocomplete and smart
suggestions so the designers don't need
to redline all of their design mocks or
their specs and the developers know what
exact variations they could possibly
choose from
our design system also uses strict
naming conventions so that our source of
truth doesn't have to be production code
as it is for many companies our source
of truth can actually start and live in
the design for example in our figma UI
kit we have all of our typography and
all of our colors all of our text types
mapped out and named based on what we
would want the functional color and type
variables to be we then map those
variables to props and provide the exact
the exact same type styles and color
styles to our components because all of
our style opinions get translated to
props in the code we're able to maintain
a strict and defined system for all of
our designs this allows for us to rarely
deviate from the system ensuring
efficiency in code and consistency in
design
as a bonus typescript can also enable
business and user trust according to a
study done by a computer science
researcher Adrian Collier using
typescript results in a 15 percent
decrease of bugs strong typing ensures
that there will be less bugs which helps
PM's and other people focused on the
business side of things
trust that your features will be more
efficient and of course the users will
appreciate experiencing less bugs as
well hopefully by this point I've
convinced you that design systems could
greatly benefit from using typescript
but I want to close out this talk by
expressing that when it comes to writing
code it's important to understand that
form follows function what does this
mean it means that the shape of our
structures and more abstractly the tools
that we choose to use and how we use
them are dictated by their functions
when it comes to web development the
purpose of everything we do is to make a
more useable and safe set of websites
and apps
so to take that a step further intent
follows impact as a developer or even a
designer your intent or lack of intent
behind anything you create follows the
impact that it has on users of the web
and on each other it's always cool to
use the newest libraries or frameworks
but it's important to gauge whether they
actually impact the users and maintain
errs positively and if the creators of
the framework had safety and usability
in mind your intent behind the software
you build and put out into the world
creates more impact than you might
expect so it's important to use the
tools that consider everyone safety and
Trust thank you
[Applause]